it's going to take a long time to to get
solar panels out there obviously you
know putting them on every
building it takes time we're getting
there um
but nuclear uh we haven't
invested in here in the united states in
a long time we haven't had a new nuclear
reactor since the early 70s france is
primarily powered by nuclear
uh japan stopped nuclear after fukushima
and
germany in a very reactionary way shut
down their nuclear reactors although
they've had days where they've had 50
percent
of their energy provided by renewals so
they could afford to do that because of
their investment
but putting all that together would it
not make sense and i'm wondering if you
would be in favor of
a really urgent deployment of
hundreds or you know dozens of nuclear
reactors
so that we stop uh burning fossil fuels
in the united states and other places
what's your position on especially for
india and china as well because china is
making dozens of
them they're doing it so what's your
position on nuclear as a bridge to get
us off of fossil fuel
um you know it's not something that i've
done a ton of research on so i don't
want to like
prognosticate but i do think that it's
nuclear gives us the opportunity to do
director capture
um in a responsible way like direct air
capture is like these giant fans or
whatever that
suck uh co2 out of the atmosphere and
inject it deep underground or turn it
into bricks
and it's a really interesting technology
and if it runs off but
what's the name of that technology d
yeah so there's there's
different types of carbon capture right
there's there's
dax which is like direct air capture
there's
bex which is like bio energy so like
burning biomass and then taking the the
leftover carbon and burying that
um there's like what i call direct ocean
capture like what we're doing
um so there's a variety of different um
carbon capture mechanisms
now the the careful thing the thing we
have to be careful about is like this
concept of additionality so
are is your if you're
even if you're putting solar panels out
and using that to
pull carbon out of the atmosphere you
have to compare
that to just using the solar panels to
prevent carbon from going up in the
first place
right so if you're if you're robbing
peter to pay paul if you're if you're
pulling off the renewable energy grid in
order to pull carbon out of the
atmosphere you have to
you have to do the analysis of like is
the
the carbon i'm emitting to from like the
natural gas plant to replace
the energy that's coming out of the
renewable grid
does that balance how much carbon i'm
pulling down so it gets really
complicated and that's why like
ultimately it's going to require
some sort of governance that's going to
wrap all this up
and like make sure all these things are
balanced because if we do it in an ad
hoc way i really worry that we're going
to lose
some of the the higher quality carbon
sequestration techniques
will will will be given um so in
relation to nuclear if we were to create
let's say in the united states
you know some of these small nuclear
reactors are now much safer
yeah if we were to create a hundred of
them and we could get over the nimbyism
of where to put them for a second
um which i think if you told people in
california right now
you know we can start reversing climate
change if you approve some nuclear
reactors
people in california who are dealing
with the smoke issue would be like yes
let's do it
right much rather have a couple of
nuclear reactors and deal with that risk
in and the new nuclear is so much safer
than fukushima which was a disaster they
knew
where they put it was below sea level
and they took that risk anyway
and they kept that risk for 30 years it
was just really dumb uh no offense yeah
i mean i've i've read a bit about like
how some of them now they fail say like
they're fail-safe so if anything
any system fails it shuts down yes um
i think that it would be oh sorry go
ahead well no i just wanted to know how
you direct air capture related to
nuclear saying
the nuclear reactor is there and so it's
throwing off so much energy you could
actually have dac going on when
it's got excess energy like i i'll be
honest like i've
i've done a lot of modeling and thinking
about how to use the ocean
right for different things like that's
kind of where my focus is um i feel like
that's where i bring like
some some sort of like a unique skill
set when when it gets to
that i just don't understand the risk
curve so like i don't want to tell you
that i think that's like a fantastic
idea i think that from from like first
principles that makes a lot of sense but
i don't have the
uh information to be able to like
balance out the risks
of this of uh nuclear energy i think
that
people are probably not looking at the
risks when they're against it
right i i bet that people aren't really
digging in on all that all the risks
associated with it and i definitely
think that um
the the status quo or
like doing nothing about carbon in the
atmosphere is like completely
unacceptable and will be looked on us
foolish